أبدأ دائمًا بالتقاط كل
القمامة التي يمكنني التخلص منها ، ثم كنس
الأجزاء الأصغر حجمًا يعمل Brogan Ingram في
مهمة أخذت غرفة المعيشة هذه من
مظهر مثل هذا إلى مظهر
تنظيف المنازل غير الصالحة للعيش مجانًا
للأشخاص الذين يعانون من مشاكل نفسية
وجسدية  الصحة لدي قائمة انتظار تضم
أكثر من 100 شخص في الوقت الحالي فقط ينتظرون
في مجتمعي لأتمكن من جعلني
أذهب إليهم لمتابعة درجة الماجستير في
علم النفس تقول إنجرام إنها منجذبة
إلى تقاطع التنظيف والصحة العقلية ،
كلنا نمر في مواسم صعبة
من  حياة بعض الناس أكثر صعوبة من
غيرهم ، وعادةً ما يكون التنظيف هو
أول شيء يتم وضعه على
اللوحة الخلفية كيف يصل الأشخاص إلى هذا
المستوى ، الأمر كله يتعلق بالتجنب ، فهم
لا يعرفون من أين يبدأون في كيفية
البدء في معالجة الأمر كما لو كانوا  لقد استسلمت
للتو في مكان سابق قمت به
الأسبوع الماضي ، وقالت إنها تعتقد
أنها ستموت للتو في الفوضى التي كانت
تخطط للتو للخروج بها.
نينغز على
مدار العامين الماضيين يوثق كل شيء على
Tick Tock تحت المقبض ليس أسوأ
منظف يرى الدموع في
عيون المرأة الجميلة عندما
رأى هي وأطفالها مطبخهم النظيف جعل كل شيء يستحق كل هذا
العناء لدينا جميعًا صفقة مختلفة
عما
نريد أن يبدو شكلنا وتسعين في المائة
من الوقت هو توقعات غير واقعية
نعد أنفسنا
لخيبة الأمل عندما
تبدأ دورة تجنب
التسويف خاصة إذا كنت تتعامل
مع الصحة العقلية أو البدنية
ويصعب عليك الاعتناء بنفسك  من
الصعب الاهتمام ببيئتك ،
فهل هناك أي نوع من النصائح الصغيرة ربما
مكان يمكنهم البدء فيه فقط حتى لا
يربكهم وربما يحدث تغيير
يبدأ صغيرًا في زاوية واحدة ويعمل في
طريقك ويتخلى عن
توقعات  الحصول على كل شيء في
لقطة واحدة ، فلا بأس إذا كان الأمر على هذا
النحو ، فهو في الواقع طبيعي أكثر مما يعتقده الناس وهناك طريقة للخروج